tout était raté ce week end à budapest
pourtant le gouvernement orban avait
prévu et promis le plus grand le plus
beau feu d'artifice d'europe pour l'as
saint-etienne c'est la fête nationale
des hongrois 40000 mèche traite à
s'embraser sur les rives du danube et
qui ferait oublier un instant aux
hongrois l'inflation l'austérité et la
guerre en ukraine cela fait six mois
aujourd'hui qu'a débuté la guerre en
ukraine le 24 février dernier les russes
envahissent et le pays l'un des
objectifs annoncés par poutine était de
défendre les séparatistes du dombass les
bombardements ont commencé ce jour là et
cibler des aéroports et plusieurs
grandes villes du pays dont la capitale
kiev
malheureusement cette petite heure à
peine avant ce grand délire
pyrotechniques et bien la météo
hongroise annonce de l'orage donc le
plus beau feu d'artifice d'europe et est
annulée puisque le gouvernement ne veut
pas prendre le risque de le maintenir
car il garde en mémoire une tempête qui
avait fait cinq morts lors de la
saint-etienne en 2006 sage décision sauf
que il n'y a pas eu d'orage enfin si
mais pas à budapest
jupiter comme vous l'avez jamais vu le
télescope spatial james webb a encore
frappé le résultat vous le voyez
saisissant capté en juillet dernier
diffusé lundi les images de la plus
grosse planète du système solaire sont
d'une précision sans précédent au niveau
notamment des aurores un phénomène
lumineux générés par les tempêtes
solaires de tous les scénarios que nous
avions anticipé le moins probable
effectivement produit a expliqué penaud
le service météorologique hongrois sur
sa page facebook le lendemain mais en
vain les médias progouvernementaux sont
furieux on réclame des têtes et la
directrice de la météo et son adjoint
doute les deux meilleurs experts du pays
sont virés sur le champ pour
incompétence quelqu'un est passé du
statut de loyal à celui de traître
pour résumer vous ne pouvez faire
confiance à
très longtemps venir un loyal est devenu
traître c'est incroyable ça rebat les
cartes totalement je me sens encore plus
en danger
j'aimerais passer plus de temps avec
vous mais mon rôle et vous traumatiser
et la mission est accomplie une vidéo
qui donne la chair de poule
cette nageuse est poursuivi par une
ombre qui grossit au fur et à mesure il
s'agit d'un requin tigre une espèce
responsable de nombreuses attaques sur
l'homme
même si ce requin de près de quatre
mètres semble plus curieux qu'agressif
cette femme au sang froid incroyable a
préféré le repousser en posant sa main
sur son nez
je trouve
sèche est arrivé si
je trouve ça totalement injuste
totalement gratuit alors justement
contrairement à toi j'ai pas l'habitude
de jouer la comédie
j'ai plus rien à dire c'est trop pour
moi vous avez un autre talent c'est un
talent avec la langue qu'est ce que vous
savez faire avec votre langue je sais
pas si c'est un talent mais du coup je
peux la plier en vagues alors attendez
attendez on met la musique de cirque
alors mathieu là du coup un tu peux la
tournée mais en fait
je vous jure que moi je suis loyal je
vous le jure si vous voulez pas éliminer
une innocente juste oublié mois dans ce
cas vous aussi je le jure sur la tête de
ma mère que j'aime plus que tout au
monde
non non l'attend là là non on en arrive
à jurer à ma très bien mais c'est comme
ça comme ça on va tout mais on va voir
ah oui c'est pas une famille nombreuse
idiot et comment vous arrivez à faire ça
aucune idée que c'est un truc de fou
mais c'est quoi c'est pas lié à la
tétine quand vous étiez petit héros ça
alors là j'en aurai pas moi qui vous
aidez moi du monde que vous arriviez à
faire ça je d'autre chose
marine dans la cuisine la moule
oui sow rennes une partie du corps
humain la moule
je suis pur bienveillante et
que même si j'ai pas la forme le fond
est là
[Musique]
alors à tous je voulais vous dire et je
le répète
je suis
totalement
innocente et loyal
il faut faire quand même les devoirs je
pense mais je sais que tu es 9e pas mais
c'est comme ça j'aime pas les raisins
sans les war z pas pourquoi
[Musique]
parce que c'est mon bébé c'est vulgos
est amer celle qui t'a créé cinq ans bah
non
c'est moi qui avais toi dans son ventre
le champion c'est entre êtres chers
loyaux vous avez éliminé à notre loyal
je souhaite à tous une bonne soirée
on est nul
il ya des doutes sur beaucoup de choses
lensois mais sur le fait qu'on soit très
khouya pas très bon goût tu serais
content c'est sûr ans